on va faire partir on a décidé de
refaire un ice boulette challenge ça a
tellement bien marché
les gens sont tellement contents saragih
tellement sur twitter et sur blue book
qu'on va envoyer deux autres personnes
les deux autres personnes qui vont faire
le reste voulait challenge sont
christophe carrière et enora malagré
tous les chalets et laura ça va ou pas
détester mais vous n'avez pas dû trouver
ou live et ça c'est super cd boulimie
bon bref il n'est pas physiquement quand
même très sale est magnifique avec lui à
l'aise hier les portes et enora et
christophe carrière qui ont offert le
ice boulet challenge alain goulet
challenge là là ils sont prêts et nora
ça va non patera une aura de carrière
sam à christophe pour l'instant ouais ça
va alors on aura j'ai une question à
vous poser
oui vous allez avoir le temps de la
danse de venance pour prendre votre
décision
oui ici j'ai quelqu'un qui est à côté de
moi qui s'appelle bertrand chamerois
vous l'aimez bien vous non pas trop
sachez que j'ai un deal à vous proposer
droit oui un big deal comme disait
lagarde
enora où vous me dites cyril j'y vais
avec christophe carrière je fais le ice
boulet challenge ouais vous allez avoir
le temps de la danse devenant ça pour
réfléchir on vient vous me dites non je
sors de cette boule et je blague ma
place à bertrand chamerois c'est une
belle probable
ouais ouais c'est on va vous laisser le
temps maintenant de venance pour
réfléchir
vous me confirmez vous pouvez pas
blairer meurtre aux jeux d'été sa mort
enora je vous avais proposé un deal et
le rac est ce que vous dites le thème
écoutez je dois pas que ce soit la bonne
solution même si bertrand est vraiment
un être que je ne peux pas saquer ouais
je suis venu dans cette galère avec
christophe je repartirai dans cette
galère
il y avait pourtant dit whitt de
personnes qui disent qu'ils veulent voir
bertrand dans la boule
j'ai pas encore dit mon dernier mot et
il va partir avant la fin de l'émission
un attention et nos rails christophe
carrière le ice bullets allen je les
juge vous dire un truc
au delà de la de la peur s'il vous plaît
faites-le pour moi pour ma maman essayer
de sauver quelques boulettes c'est ok
merci merci merci j'adore il y aura que
oui oui ça y est allé attention
attention on va préparer la catapulte
armée la catapulte dessus armée la
catapulte ya les ja l'autre collège paul
valéry la bible qu'il en est vraiment de
baume au coeur
quel enfer attention et se combien de
temps qu'on attende le sympa 9 7 6 5 4 3
laurent justin long
exceptionnel
non là les pauvres à la pomme en irlande
elle une boule l'escaladé qu'est ce que
vous dites est loin maintenant maman et
non à savalou tu as trouvé des boulettes
voilà
laura brown christophe carrière allez
venez nous rejoindre dès lors à la la la
la la
si vous nous aidez sur des beats et
touche pas mon public en direct a bien
sûr oh là là les pauvres et vous avez
les cauchois cette séquence
quand je vois ce que tu sais quoi je me
dis aucun rapport avec le thème de
l'émission touche pas au sérieux je
comprends pas mais bon goûter
voilà c'est fait c'est fait